[Music]
all right in unhealthy entertainment
news Oh submitted by mafia Queen Nicki I
took the crown from Geo Oh Pamela
Anderson wants all of reality TV to be
canceled why the queen of Baywatch has
now proclaimed all reality TV shall be
closed why do you think because of her
because she's sex tapes that were always
leaked nope because she's irrelevant now
nope oh man she didn't age well dude
yeah she got some rock done she got some
work because she was pitching this show
and they didn't pick it up so she
doesn't want anything else to be here
yeah because they are not reality
no ok so Pamela Anderson is calling for
an end to reality TV because there are
reports that almost 40 people I've
killed themselves after being on a
reality TV can deal with this yeah it
was really high yeah so a lot of these
people have mental health issues and
it's really just like greedy agents
trying to get money out of these people
and then these people find fame and
they're not equipped to deal with it
yeah and so yeah that's true like
suicides have overnight Fame Kim if
you're not prepared for that [ __ ] it
[ __ ] you hard as if you're already
mentally fragile yeah I know kind of
people that kind of go on really shows
or that get selected to go on rally
because they're funny is entertaining
yeah it's the the narrative is it's
already written out for you so if you're
the villain people have this person
people don't realize that reality is not
reality yeah look at this human being
like a piece of trash for the rest of
their lives like you do today I can't
believe you were [ __ ] such a [ __ ] on
the show but that was what the producers
told me that or they
edit it so that you look like a [ __ ]
even though that's not even what you say
[ __ ] have you seen um what's that show
called uh Jersey Shore no it's like real
real real life you know it's that show
that's like about it's a lifetime show
but it's about golden girl I think backs
that The Bachelor is like behind the
scenes of The Bachelor but the scripted
show it's a drama it what's it called
it's real life no it's called I think
real life er
okay well let's explain well anyway it's
like they go into it's a scripted show
and it's a drama but it's the main
characters are the producers of a
bachelor type show and it's about how
they trick people into saying certain
things so that they can get sound bites
and drama and all this stuff and they
kind of mess with real people's lives
and there are like deaths on the show
and cheating in all kinds of [ __ ] there
was some big drama around The Biggest
Loser
where they were the agents were trying
to get them to take diet pills yeah but
it was like the harmful [ __ ] like you
know
yeah diet pills and then and they would
like [ __ ] with them and and and like
like dangle a doughnut in front of them
or some [ __ ] you know yeah they're
treated like a highly scripted and
controlled environment where they're
trying to control everything that
happens you know what they even do they
even hire psychologists and they go oh
this personality and that personality
perfect that's gonna make some good
drama there
we got a bipolar person we got this
person over here with high anxiety
they're gonna [ __ ] fight
that's what they do so type in right
here and this was reckless they're gonna
fight Pam Anderson has been on Big
Brother dancing on ice and Dancing with
the Stars so she's been on reality TV
and she brands it an epidemic of
ugliness she and quotes you are usually
bullied into doing TV like this by
agents fighting over Commission's you're
left without any great amount of joy or
money you feel used dirty and with no
feeling of accomplishment and you couple
that with mental health issues and boom
you
yourself that's why she looks old rough
now I feel so sad the way she went down
cuz I'm like Baywatch man she had
hottest the nicest titties in Hollywood
ever did all the Baywatch girls at the
prime like what Carmen Electra that's
all they were hot dude they were like
that was all that was so awesome 51 now
so it's not like dy no she looks like a
no but I think it's like he a 30 year
old you know like she's she's all I
remember is her running on a beach
really slow and having her bagina in her
face there's there's there's getting old
but she's like the stripper that got oh
she's not like that
she was very very very sexualized
because she was a plan money to hold on
to her sexuality yeah this was just some
1g way this is like this is like if you
saw this this was like your friend's mom
and like that and she wasn't a movie
star like you'd be like aw it's just a
regular that is a very good photo over
though no I would just think damn she
got something this is it was the promo
photo what the [ __ ] is that guy was when
she was going dancing dancing with
dancing on ice or yeah but oh yeah so
she's just I'm speaking from experience
and she's just hates she's seen a lot of
people broke enough for reality TV and
it big the Big Brother psychologist Emma
Kenny branded these figures of suicides
horrendous
what's Big Brother saying that Jew
brother oh it's what they take a bunch
of like semi celebrities like Beulah
celebrities and they put them in a house
together
and you just it's like real worlds but
with yeah but if there wasn't any drama
or war the entertainment be well exactly
if that's that's what reality TV drives
off I actually what am I just watching
people live their lives
that's seeing what happens naturally it
would just be we just have to be filmed
over a very long period of time like
vlogs
yeah exactly as we're dogs aren't like
that either Bellevue blog blogs are
different though cuz vlogs you stopped
performing I would see a Pamela Anderson
bang oh yeah there you go yeah there's
you said what I was seeing a Pamela
Anderson mukbang oh you should watch
Trisha Paytas channel I would see a
Nicholas che Nicolas Cage baking a cake
I would too yeah because you would have
to wait for real drama to happen it
would just you only get like maybe five
episodes out the whole year but when
that [ __ ] happens it [ __ ] happens now
I should give it was constantly recorded
yeah like [ __ ] Nicolas Cage it's like
one sick and tired of you [ __ ] making
a spy and it doesn't come out right you
know where some [ __ ] I don't know it'd
be amazing so you want a celebrity just
but like living their life I want to see
how they actually [ __ ] are I wanted
to use a mouse yeah they still how they
deal with like marital problem I want
them fight I think that's what you want
a Truman Show yes I think that's what
Punk'd was so good cuz when they set it
up like you get to see completely that
like you see like Justin Timberlake like
freaking out like oh that's my photos
flamboyant as a [ __ ] when he saw
like like there's not one where they set
up a fire to like the rocks trailer and
he was gonna beat the living [ __ ] out of
the security guard see all the indc
there's one where they had a boat
explode in front of my Taylor Swift's
house and Taylor Swift started like
freaking out she's all crying as [ __ ] I
had me on Punk and all my [ __ ] started
exploding I would've been like it's a
Monday this guy dude car stolen
alright on it - everything is really
good people that you don't expect I
think that they they don't know I think
that they actually do get pretty used to
love the yo mama
show with will do better that [ __ ] dude
look I don't Rob your mama battles I
just remember one joke that for some
reason had me dying laughing it was
because there was this guy he had these
spikes on his wrist and he was also a
fat guy and then this guy said he was
like he'd even make a yo mama joke he
goes he goes a lotta [ __ ] that you have
those meat tenderizers on your wrist
I started laughing my ass off for some
reason because the guy looks so
embarrassed about
yeah it is like I should have not worn
these things I know he's looking at his
wrists like he was like oh I like
reality TV that's like centered around a
person and their character like robbing
big oh yeah yeah yeah he's big homie
yeah or like like those fixer-upper
shows like oh yeah it's positive and
it's not my ride
drama my right was dope I ride like they
get what's a Johanna chip and Joanna
Gaines show where they fix people's
houses and stuff they find them they
like this dumpy ass property and they
make it look like a dream castle there's
like a Airbnb one right now on Netflix I
forgot the name of it but my home or
something
I forgot that is a very real my home no
but yeah they like fix and flip it and
it's pretty dope this is my home calm
that's admirable cosmo but there ain't
gonna change just because Pamela
Anderson I mean if people stop watching
and people stop signing up for it then
it won't exist exactly people love it
people would just do it on their own on
Instagram or on like YouTube or whenever
like it's such a it's always gonna be
people love seeing other people be train
wrecks that's just always how it's been
you know really news in line cuz then
they go walk my life is bad but I think
so I'm not like them it's loser all the
time cuz I was like at least I'm not fat
like them they would cry yeah I always
saw it as like these people are so
delusional that they don't live in my
world so Fame obsessed yeah they just
don't really show I I liked oh there's
two of them the first one is America's
Top Model ooh I like that a lot those
are cuz they have like little mini
competitions
that's like American Idol and then the
other one I liked was um [ __ ] how did a
survivor know I know father
sure yes Jersey Shore just so out of
this war like it was it was like a
guilty pleasure because I'm like these
people are not real my first favorite
reality show was was watching Ozzie oh
yeah interesting you guys never watched
Teen Mom no that was depressing made me
sad do you guys watch real worlds yes
thank you yeah I mean the real world was
the first one I never watched that one
yeah it was like basically people get
their cars towed and you see how they
react but it was so fun yes I remember
because they they did a karate what I
mean they came out and [ __ ] them up
karate strike but it was like her spin
around the cops huh cops
that's the original reality original
world star that was train wrecks again
like it's all centered above a Festa
that's why drama always works well on
YouTube as well too
well if you look at sitcoms is just a
scripted train wreck like pain it's not
funny to the character but it's funny to
us watching this I Love Lucy train
wrecks every day I guess when there's
real life consequences and people just
don't recover and they die if people
don't think about these people as being
actual their characters like we're all
characters right when people talk about
us and say [ __ ] about there were not
human beings yeah when you're on a
screen and someone's home like there's a
wall it's like there aren't real people
that I know yeah of course cuz the [ __ ]
that they say like in the comics or to
you or whatever they won't say that to
people in real life yeah wish you would
know they're say they're saying it as
like because we're characters so I mean
that's read to do it even they pick
their villains they pick their heroes
yeah eight-year-olds are so neat you're
so mean no they're like you guys
sometimes I'm like yeah you guys can
really form sentences really well
dude I bet you they could type better
than they can speak oh for sure only
figure here oh there's something here
David what you said was so rude about
this this and that I'm like hey day sex
everything and then you go to their page
and if they're like in this video you
said this I was like yeah I'm a
hypocrite like dissect every little
thing you say would you mean by that
does that mean that you hate this race
of people it's like no I wonder what
will happen if we Egham are like yeah
you're right yeah we do what will happen